so we'll just hold up in court we asked
George Washington University law
professor Jonathan Turley I find it
interesting here well first of all the
one thing I would say Honda has going
for him is Abby Lowell who I respect is
one of the top D.C attorneys do you
agree with that
yeah I think the world of Abby
all right so my question is
to me it seems very clever that they
went after the IRS not the
whistleblowers individually now is there
a legal reason for that because I would
think that if I'm one of the lawyers for
the whistleblowers they go after my guy
I'm probably going to want discovery on
Hunter Biden which would not work out
well for him would it
no I can understand what Abby Lola is
doing but I don't think it's going to
work uh he's trying to take these shots
uh for his client but under the federal
law the committee is allowed to make
public tax information in fact the
Senate reports supporting this law goes
into that public disclosure power here
the committee invited the two
whistleblowers to a public hearing
because they believed that this
information should be made public and
those two whistleblowers in the hearing
went at Great Lengths to be to say they
were going to stay only within the
confines of what they told the committee
they refused to answer a number of
questions so I don't believe that Abby
Lowell has a strong case here I think
it'll fall apart he could get a
sympathetic judge on the trial level but
I don't think he can hold this together
on appeal
I think there are so many questions
Professor uh why did Joe lie repeatedly
about ever talking to his brother his
his son or anybody for that matter uh
you know why why was he involved in all
these conversations with with these
foreign business partners why was he
meeting some of them at the Cafe Milano
uh what did Hunter offer at a time that
they admit he was addicted to drugs and
and Hunter himself admitted he had no
experience why are they getting tens and
tens of millions of dollars a lot of it
coming from our top geopolitical foes
what did Eddie Biden do for all of this
money what did Hunter do what did the
grandkids do why all the shell companies
you know everyone keeps you know with
with the liberal Mantra oh there's no
evidence at all whatsoever I'm not
buying this no evidence there's a lot of
doors open here that indicate a lot of
untoward things happen here
no I think it's a case of willful
blindness to say that there's no
evidence many in the media now rather
belatedly admit that Hunter Biden was
engaged in influence peddling he was
suggesting he was selling access to his
father but they insist that's only an
illusion that all of these corrupt
Figures were just Chumps that they
fleeced for all this money but how do
you know that I mean that's the reason
you have an impeachment inquiry and
instead of revealing information that it
could clear up this information the
White House and Hunter Biden are
resisting these efforts and that's why
an impeachment inquiry is so important
you know this latest attack on the IRS
whistleblowers I discussed back in
February when there was a meeting of the
team planning a scorched Earth campaign
against Witnesses what's interesting
about that meeting is it was leaked to
The Washington Post Hunter Biden's team
wanted witnesses to know that they were
going to go after them they wanted them
to know that they were going to go
aggressive and Target Witnesses and
that's what we've seen they've sued the
owner of the computer shop in an
absolutely ridiculous counter suit where
Hunter Biden is saying that he still
can't
confirm that this is actually his laptop
or these emails are authentic but he
does claim that his privacy was invaded
when the contents were revealed well how
does that work so these are all efforts
to attack witnesses to draw them out
financially expose them to litigation
but it's not going to work this
impeachment query is on the road and
he's going to be getting subpoenas and
he's going to have to answer questions
the question I have is why don't you
want to answer those questions why
doesn't the president or Hunter Biden
release some of these Financial records
show that this money didn't go to to
them from untoward sources instead
they're being everything but helpful
all right Jonathan Turley thanks for
that great analysis as always we
appreciate it when we come back hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else